Black Adam grabs the guy by the neck and  literally electrocutes him until he  dissolves melts and turns to Ash what  was in store for us because we thought  they were quick shots but the director  wanted to have him you know electrocute  him for more than a couple of seconds  and so that was uh one of the most  challenging shots that we have because I  I really feel that in visual effects  when you include characters humans  with visual effects I think that comes  very complex and it has to hold up as  photo real and and because it's a human  it's not an alien character we know how  certain properties of face eyes skin you  know sort of reacts on certain  attributes that they have that any child  could say is that human or not and so we  had to make a digital human out of one  of the mercenaries and we had to we had  a fries what was we call them  electrocuted Baddie that was a quote of  the shot